she was a grossest girl who became the
iron lady and last time inflation was
this high she was in charge
margaret thatcher liked to compare the
public finances to a household budget
and in her hometown those are tight we
just came up with a battle plan i think
didn't we where we thought well if it's
going to be till the end of 2023 we just
be really careful now we budget we do
cut things out that we don't need
the current pm has stretched out his
summer vacation following up his
slovenian spa break with a hellenic
holiday
hi everybody it's fantastic to be here
in northern ireland as the battle for
his job reaches belfast well what we
know is inflation has been caused by a
global price shock after covert so what
i would do is immediately reduce taxes
reversing the ni increase inflation is
the greatest challenge facing the new
prime minister now i have the right plan
to get a grip of inflation to support
the people who most need our help with a
cost of living
labor want action now the government's
completely lost control of the economy
it needs to get a grip but instead of
getting a grip we've got a zombie
government
tory members in the constituency of
grantham and stamford are getting
concerned about inflation that plus
climate change of course um is the worst
enemy that we have
you're noticing that increase in cost
and actually that's why the decision i
think we'll take with the leadership is
really important to get that inflation
down everything is um increasing you
know i've got four children two moved
out and one has moved back because she
can't afford the hiking rent the high
kid food whoever gets
the leadership and becomes prime
minister i do not envy them one bit
that's a diamond tiara jeweler john
dawson has been in the trade almost 60
years and recently he's seen a shift i
think we've noticed a dramatic
change because it's a it's a case of the
haves and the have-nots if you look at
the people who walk through the door now
there are they are far far wealthier we
have a the the clientele is a wealthy
clientele they're just people on smaller
incomes people yes because it's no
longer
in their gift to be able to afford
something
the uk economy is taking a battering
and without government intervention soon
many more people may fall through the
cracks joe pike sky news stanford